[Music]
[Applause]
hi and welcome to research and focus
again I'm Gretchen Hugh's Inga and I'm
joined now by two heavy hitters and
systems and networking Albert Greenberg
the CVP of asier networking and Victor
Bal director of mobility and networking
at Microsoft Research it's great to have
you both with us today there's many
projects that you've both been involved
in bringing to life and I'd like to
hover at the 10,000 foot view kind of in
the cloud if you will and talk about the
big issues and big problems that you're
instrumental in bringing it to life and
I'll start with you Victor if the cloud
is too big to fail how our researchers
dealing with the challenges of
scalability reliability and availability
even as Moore's Law breathes its last
few breaths I don't know if cloud is too
big to fail I think we don't want it to
feel ever but but yeah the the obviously
would scale the challenges become
extraordinary you know so for example we
have millions of devices that are
connected to the cloud and especially if
you think about networking and all these
devices have to move packets from one
point to another and they they are
across the globe across the entire
planet we have you know more than 30,000
miles of lip fiber for example we have
hundreds across the globe we have more
than hundred thousand miles inside the
network inside the data centers so yeah
so then when when you when you think
about these problems and anything can go
wrong anyplace and if it goes wrong you
can actually bring down massive number
of businesses or a large portion of the
of the cloud can go down so this is a
very stressful situation if you think
about it so this requires discipline in
the way you approach it
this requires science so that you can
reason about things when they fail and
and this requires the ability to recover
from failure so fast that the customer
doesn't actually realize that and so
when you think about these problems you
start to feel you start to think that it
stretches every bit of technology that
we have built in many different spaces
so you know from protocol design
to sort of availability to sort of
fault-tolerance all this stuff gets very
very stressed and so researchers tend to
find these problems and then tend to
once they've identified they work on it
so yeah there's a slew of problems I can
talk about but you yeah no I I think
that's great I mean it's it's a
challenging system before the cloud and
now that we've got all the additional
layers it makes it even harder and more
challenging for researchers Albert you
go way back
the two of you go way back actually but
but as your network he can Microsoft
research go way back together the
beginnings of many projects were in
Azure actually I think you were
incubated there - yes how would you
characterize the relationship between
systems research and its reification in
products today well yeah so I also as
you mentioned started it in Microsoft
research working with and for Victor and
the but we what we knew at the time is
that Microsoft was going through a
transformation I mean we're we are the
new platform for everything in computing
and storage and networking is the cloud
it's amazingly exciting and why
reliability is so so central to it so we
really are transforming everything in
life and and work in in this field and
and we could tell at the time that that
what we had to work with the raw
ingredients would not work out for us we
had to invent a lot and so we had the
team with the product groups inside
Microsoft incubate and prove our ideas
as well as other industries and consumed
components and hardware and software
from them and then put together this new
platform for the entire world and that's
why we're so excited every day to go to
work is we have a huge amount of work up
other people's work running on our cloud
and it's growing how does that when you
have other people's things that you have
to incorporate with your things what
particularly does that do to the the big
picture well a good example is what we
call disaggregation
you know so we in in in this
infrastructure it used to be for example
a networking you would buy a box and in
this big box there would be the power
the the software the hardware it was one
proprietary monolith and in the
disaggregated world where we have to
achieve incredible levels of reliability
and safety and so forth we know
everything about what's in that box and
control it ourselves but we do we don't
necessarily build all the hardware so we
have to you know go to class work with
with partners in fact one of the first
classes I took when I was in Microsoft
research was with one of our hardware
partners and they were revealing the
theory of operations of their parts and
sitting next to near that you know
traditional networking companies Cisco
and juniper and so forth and then you
know here's the Microsoft understanding
everything and so we could take I knew
that something was changing and and and
that was the opportunity that this IRA
Gatien afforded us Victor Microsoft just
announced the open network emulator
which is a big big story but emulation
is not a new thing and so how does the
open network emulator bring us to the
next level of royal reliability what's
what's new about it yeah yeah so you
know both of us have talked about
reliability or availability right so I
just want to make that point
crystal-clear here when we have a lot of
our customers depend on us that should
mean something and Microsoft's name
means something that means we will be up
for you 24/7 365 nothing will happen and
as Albert was pointing out sort of
networking is a substrate which keeps
the cloud alive yeah you know without
networking you would just have servers
and that's not good enough right so so
so then as you had asked me in the
earlier question about what sort of
challenges research do so availability
reliability is a massive challenge
stepping back from open emulator just a
minute there is a field of research
around network theory
or in fact software verification the
idea there is that before you touch
anything significant like inside a
network or server you want to verify
that it won't have an impact so we built
this open network emulator and it is so
good just to sort of praise ourselves a
little bit that when and and I think
Albert can testify to some of that stuff
what I'm saying now because it's so good
that when operators or engineers network
engineers go and change something
somewhere in the world anywhere in the
world you're great across the planet
they actually don't know if they're
changing the network or the emulator
because it is such an it mimics the the
networks so well that they can't tell
the difference but the beauty is that
they are actually changing the emulator
we have built and we then test out
everything before we will go and touch
the network and by testing out
everything before we touch the network
we can ensure that it works in the past
that was not the case in the past people
would go and make some configuration
changes here and there and and in their
head the logic would be fine but their
interdependencies are so large and so
complicated that if you touch something
one place it can have impact somewhere
else in a big way and you know it's
sometimes even beyond human capacity to
understand that but the emulator avoids
that one more thing I would like to say
here is that the value of this is so
large that we actually thought that it's
actually good to share it with the world
so we're making it available we are
maybe letting you know for example the
other industry folks to see how it is
built
we are we want our students who are
going to graduate school and understand
trying to build do work on large scale
and networking be able to use the
emulator to do their research on that
stuff so yeah we're very excited about
so the open opens open network emulator
is open source
yeah can you speak to that a little bit
about the rationale behind that I will
yeah so me first let me just talk about
how this thing operates if you imagine
you wrote a piece of software and it
could be for a commercial router or one
that where our software and let's say a
cisco juniper or a sonic which is ours
and you know like you can imagine like
the brain of that thing goes to sleep
you know and usually when it wakes back
up its the real hardware there and it's
like manipulating you know physical
hardware this thing wakes up and it's it
thinks there's the hardware there it's
pretty you know it up it doesn't know
it's that it it up we virtualized the
hardware so it's it's actually exactly
doing what it would do in the physical
world it we've faked it out to think
that the the real hardware is there that
means there is no modeling it is the
real thing running and that's that that
means that you know if you watch people
operating on it and they can't tell
either it's it's the it is identical its
woken up in the cloud now the other
thing that it illustrates is the need to
use the cloud to build the cloud there
was there was no technology ever to sort
of have this thing wake up and think
it's on a physical but we virtualized
everything in the cloud now it can do it
and then we can we can build networks of
you know thousands and thousands of
these switches virtualized and they're
talking to each other and we can find
bugs we found hundreds of bugs before
they ever got out no one ever found out
about them and we did a lot of work
without so it's it's it's it's really
it's like virtual reality but I mean it
is it is the real thing running in in
Azure yeah and I'll just add to that a
little bit so just to sort of make this
even more strong for people who do
understand some of this stuff in
networking so the past had been a lot
about modeling like modeling protocols
in fact and then and licking at
thickness back and maybe turning that
into model and then using that to do
some verification this illuminates all
that so as Albert has you know very very
nicely articulated that by by removing
those that sort of things we are as he
said any issue that the hardware vendors
may have that's all captured in the
emulator and that is why are we have
such faith and
dependency on this and it was has it has
it been deployed widely already or yes
yes so it we its deployed widely and we
like two hours ago I was watching it
running right before a major maintenance
we we don't want to touch anything
without running this emulator and it's
not that we we always we didn't learn
anything here that like we didn't fix
any bugs but we don't always know the
default behaviors or the exact
environmental x' so it is it is part of
our release process part of our
management of change process to run it
all the time and by the way there's a
lot of innovation beyond just faking out
the the software to think it's on
physical there's other innovation
because it could burn up too many hours
in the cloud so we have to figure out
smart ways to make it economical to run
it yeah there's also scoping like how
long how big a network do you Emily I
would imagine you've got a lot of
feedback on this from the deployment
what's the feedback you're getting from
customers and other businesses so the
beautiful thing is we've this year done
a project called regional networking
where we moved more circuits in in weeks
and months than we ever moved in the
history of Microsoft before and the
customers didn't notice it's it just
worked and that's because we rehearsed
we got good at it and we found the bugs
through this emulator before doing it so
customers don't feel a thing
the industry is super excited by the the
the networking industry has has seen
some papers and some blogs and they're
there they they want to consume it and
it's you could not do this without the
cloud that's why it's now right it's
enabled this to happen yes but also
because it needs to happen in the cloud
that's right I mean the just we need all
these cloud technologies to build and
design and run
the cloud so just and it's a real good
collaboration we're in researching
product to yes the other question you
asked was about traffic flow and how
it's increasing and how it's impacting
everything so at the moment we have we
have capacity we have a lot of capacity
we have invested in it we are managing
it it's all good but you're right things
are growing faster and as we make our
networks more accessible more broadly
available across the planet it's gonna
keep going up so that does present you
know problems to us and it also presents
our challenges of how we're going to
grow our networks with it
so I have a lot of faith in optical
technology and we have a tremendous
amount of investment in Microsoft
Research on on that so you know there
are labs there are people in in our
Redmond lab which is where I live
working on this and then we have very
very smart individuals in Cambridge lab
who are been working on this for a very
long time but this will give you a sense
of how this means so you know when it's
a single wavelengths we can move you
know tens of terabytes or their bits per
second of traffic now we have the an
optical is very much like virus and
Wireless is a very mature technology and
so you can apply these wireless things
that we've learned in a wireless space
into optics - so for example recently
one of the researchers in our group
figured out that by changing the
modulation you can go from 100 gigabits
per second 250 cases per second without
really changing any hardware in the same
fiber same you know we've length and so
that and so similarly now you know we're
looking at things that using multiple
wavelengths for that so even though this
is going up and we are working very hard
to solve these problems of being able to
sort of scale up but I have tremendous
amount of confidence that we can measure
up and match and provide enough
bandwidth to the world even as the
demands go right so circling back to the
product and research
symbiosis as it were and Victor's
talking about the tension between risk
and let's call it a product deadline do
you build risk into the product roadmap
situation yeah we absolutely do we think
about risk of all types of all the time
that's part of the driving that risk
down and you know it's one of the the
greatest ways to to manage that it's
just you know leverage Microsoft
Research I mean they have the mind space
they have the tools they have the
expertise and out then they have the you
know grit to to work with us and you
know solve the I think you know problems
that have never even been seen before at
and and then see their ideas implemented
so you know I to me it the it makes no
sense not to be fantastic partners with
Microsoft Research and so it just
happens and it's it's an immune ich
resource for Microsoft I don't think
anybody else no other company in the
world has something like Microsoft
Research a dozen PhDs that you can call
on to say hey how would you fix this
question I actually feel I honestly feel
that if you look at all the cloud
providers in networking we are the best
and I said in a very in part of it is
just because yeah we work very well
together and you know like I said many
researchers are now in product and but
from there we sort of understand the
pains and we understand the constraints
that they work in and and so we work
very well and it's been great oh well as
we close I just want to get from each of
you what your goal or vision about this
looks like in the future let's just say
that a networked world and all the
things that you're doing are wildly
successful what does it look like in the
real world in the future well we we are
we are creating the future I think we
are imagining what that's going to be
like and building it every day we what
what we are achieving is
part reliability but we're also
achieving security fantastic speed
everything works fast and works as
designed and it's supportable you don't
have to figure it out there's no
friction so I think you know those are
you know common things we just keep
getting better and better but I think
you know to some degree you know as as
the the whole world moves into the cloud
just as we in the case of one had to use
the cloud to build the cloud we're
seeing the new capabilities enable us to
do new and better things and we are we
are and so that I think the we will just
keep expanding in greater and greater
circles and I think the will change the
hardware will change the software will
change the data science will change
whatever needs to be changed to to
realize this vision where you know all
of the world's computing is running on
the Microsoft cloud Victor so what can I
say I shared this vision with Albert by
here's what I'll say I would love to
eliminate Albert's job so so hired and
first so exciting what I mean here is
that there is you know you asked for the
vision of course this is a very
difficult thing to do but we are we want
to build the most reliable the most
secure the most accessible the the low
latency fastest network in the world in
the planet and we want to make it so
that we we want to build technologies
that if something bad happens it heals
itself we are able to the systems are
smart enough to be able to sort of say
where the problem is how do I fix it
myself potentially you learn it and then
just fix itself up and so I was joking
about it I think we need Albert like
crazy here and this is you know he's but
but you get the point so in some sense
that's a very hard challenge and and the
interesting thing to me is that as
building stuff you actually learned so
much you can start to apply it in other
domains as well so it's not just about
networking a lot of the data Sciences
Albert was referring to a lot of the the
new signs that we are creating is very
applicable to other spaces as well we
haven't talked much about Wireless too
but the last hop a lot of the world is
mobile now and everybody is using smart
phones and laptop I mean moving around
and so we have to fix that we have to
make that as great as we are making the
cloud great so this work to do and but
but we are getting I think we both have
jobs for a while yet anyway and I'd have
to say there's a lot of things that
don't happen to us that we don't know
that you made not happen to us so I
appreciate that and I appreciate you
both coming in here Albert
and Victor it's been insightful and
inspiring thanks Gretchen yeah yeah and
thank you for joining us on research in
focus for this session we hope you'll
come back for the next one
[Music]
[Applause]